about you uh I don't seriously do only
fans but both my parents know about
everything I do and have done and
they're both extremely supportive
including the stripping yeah no
seriously like my mom will like ask me
to send her a video she like takes it
too far sometimes wrong okay my parents
do not know but I grew up in a very
conservative Christian household so that
is a conversation that I prepared myself
for the day they do find out I mean
you're on the podcast it's all good I
don't know they still don't know it's
been two and a half years and they some
found out but you know one day they will
and we'll deal with what do you think is
the uh
the disowner you think I don't think
they would fully disown me but I would
definitely get some Stern conversations
Stern conversation